alright the facts were very unusual I
think as you've hopefully summarized
them I think it's important to bear in
mind that the claimant was the only
daughter and mrs. island was the only
daughter of her late mother the father
had pre deceased the mother but there
had been this very long estrangement as
a result of which the mother decided to
make a will leaving her estate which was
worth just under half a million pounds
to charity to animal charities expressly
saying I don't want my daughter to
benefit from my will and from my estate
those are quite a long court battle
actually this is the fifth decision
we've had in this case which has
culminated in a decision yesterday by
the Court of Appeal in effect saying
that the trial judge who originally I
think it's now 2007 seven or eight years
ago had decided to award fifty thousand
pounds as a lump sum to the claimant to
mrs. eyelid that got it wrong and that
that award should be increased in the
way you've just explained I've been part
of the decision-making process but about
the Court of Appeals seems to have been
based on the daughter's financial
circumstances very much so I think it is
a very much a fact-specific decision I
think the Court of Appeal the judgement
makes it very clear that all the various
factors that the statute requires the
court to take into account have to be
taken into account carefully on the
facts of the specific case but by
fact-specific do you mean that this
doesn't serve as precedent that we're
not going to be seeing adverts on you
know mid-morning television for a law
firms telling us have you been diddled
out of your will please give us a call I
can't put the possibility of those
adverts beyond beyond doubt I don't
think the case changes the law in any
dramatic way I do lots of these sorts of
cases and I don't think it is a
precedent which for people like me means
the law has significantly changed I
think it is a fact-specific
decision but isn't isn't that isn't
there a presumption when it comes to
looking at a will that the views of the
deceased should take precedence over
over pretty much anything else not over
anything else the Court of Appeal makes
it clear that the deceased wishes were
one of the factors to be taken into
account in the setting that her
daughter's claim for financial provision
but it's only one as you said another
factor was hearth competing needs
another factor was the needs of the
beneficiaries of the will which were
Charities and the court said well they
I think slightly oddly they said
charities don't have needs are not
deemed to have needs in in a way that is
competing to those of a daughter who is
in very difficult financial
circumstances which on the evidence she
certainly was to essentially draw on
some free legal advice here if I excuse
me if I wanted to disinherit my children
or your grandchildren or whatever else
how would I go about doing that I mean
in this case the that there was a letter
written alongside the will which made
clear that she didn't want any for funds
to go yeah I think it's fair to say that
this case illustrates that it's very
difficult to deliberately disinherit
someone altogether and of course it's
fact-specific so whether the right
answer is actually leave the person you
want to disinherit something rather than
nothing that might be a solution it
might be that leaving one's assets to
another person who is in need who has
competing needs will make it more
difficult for someone to claim in these
sorts of cases I think the short answer
is there I take go and see a solicitor
and make a will because it's very much
the advice will depend very much on the
specific facts of the case it seems it
seems awfully strange that you write
something but then the courts
interpreted a different way but then
again we've got to keep you guys in
business going in at some point Edward
here thanks very much attack thank you